the idea of robots taking human jobs
might bring to mind a scene like this
but it's not Hardware that has white
collar workers concerned it's rapidly
advancing software since artificial
intelligence is doing a lot more than
finishing emails perhaps the biggest
nightmare is the looming new Industrial
Revolution the erosion of the middle
class
already one of America's most serious
problems
could get much worse with AI if we
ignore it here's how AI is already
taking over tasks at White Collar jobs
and why employees and companies are both
excited and concerned for the future of
work
generative AI can auto-complete your
sentences write feature length films or
organize your calendar and tools using
it like chat GPT are taking on an
increasing role in White Collar work
they can create first drafts of
documents presentations images video and
product designs currently 25 of work
tasks could be automated by AI in the US
according to Goldman Sachs research
generative AI helped make this ad and
this one too the company advertised here
said creating the image for this AI
generated ad cost about 10 times less
than traditional methods this works much
in the same way as other kinds of AI
which are using statistical methods on
large amounts of data processing that
through computational Power and then
generating out a computer vision system
that says this image looks a lot like
these other cats that I've been trained
on generative AI is is functionally very
similar it goes beyond creating images
alphabet is now using AI to run
anti-money laundering surveillance
programs at Banks like HSBC and says
it's cutting out human error and when
the transactional data and illicit
behaviors change as they do so does the
AML AI engine for some tech companies AI
is contributing to job cuts a May report
said nearly 4 000 Tech workers lost
their jobs to AI artificial intelligence
is also eliminating future positions
take IBM as an example its CEO said the
company could replace workers with AI I
do believe that AI is going to replace a
lot of what I'm calling white-collar
clerical jobs so the the ones that are
much more repetitive the ones where
people do the same task again and again
and again I think a good 30 percent of
those roles could go away over five
years companies are making evaluations
about future hiring on the basis of what
they project AI to be capable of doing
that's a much more tenuous area an IBM
spokesman said the company was still
hiring for thousands of positions I
think that what we've seen in past
deployments of AI is that it's
frequently used as a justification for
layoffs but it doesn't necessarily mean
that it is effectively replacing what
human workers are capable of or that
it's increasing workers productivity
Dropbox laid off 16 of its Workforce in
April but not to replace workers like
IBM it said it wanted to invest more in
AI which meant cutting elsewhere so we
see
demand growing for these products a lot
faster than we could have anticipated
and I think you could have seen the
technology coming but just the way that
the interest went vertical is something
that's way ahead of schedule from from
our expectation at openai execs say
there may be more work I think that like
the kind of sum total of what is going
to be needed to make use of the
technology as a maximally productive
technology and kind of inflect that
productivity curve up in the world will
actually require more man hours on top
than uh than you think but across
Industries workers and executives are
cautiously looking ahead
ai's role in television and film
production is a key point of
negotiations between The Writers Guild
of America and the studios
speaking to the Wall Street Journal
about the strike the co-showrunner for
the handmaid's tale laid out the
writer's Union's concerns
you know we can tell we could tell from
the negotiations that the studios wanted
to had a plan and we could deduce that
that plan was probably one writer in a
room with one or two machines creating
an entire show Studios have said they
are committed to discussing the use of
AI with the wga the wga strike I think
is a really important
moment to be paying attention to because
it's a place where workers have taken
the Forefront in putting AI at the front
and center of their negotiations about
their working conditions if it's coming
for us the creators of imaginary worlds
it is literally going to come for
everyone but there may still be time to
figure out how to best integrate AI into
the workplace so I think it's really
important that in the present moment we
preserve space for a public conversation
around the deployment of AI systems that
ensures that they're working in the
public interest in workers interest and
as well as an employer's interests
foreign